[Music]
good afternoon
so it's March and right around this time
I think about spring cleaning the person
I think about is Marie kondo who is an
expert in organizing your home
I'm not here to talk to you about
decluttering but I am here to tell you
about an idea that will spark Joy
my name is Amy pragel and I'm here to
talk to you about acts of kindness
I have a four-year-old daughter and a
few months ago she had the day off from
preschool so I took her to breakfast we
went to our local coffee shop and a few
minutes into eating a young man in his
20s walked in he went up to the first
person in line and said will you buy me
breakfast
the man said no
he went to the second person same answer
now in this time I had a couple things
running in my mind should I buy him
breakfast is he going to ask me to do
the same
I have my daughter with me should I be
doing this at this time
in the next decision I thought this was
the perfect time to do this so I raised
my hand and said I will buy you
breakfast
fast forward into the car my daughter
asked me why did that man not have money
to buy breakfast and I said to her we're
always in different circumstances in
life as people and if we have something
we should share with others
I thought she got it at the time but I
wasn't sure as much as a four-year-old
could get
well a few weeks after that at dinner
unprompted she said Mama
I want to share with you your favorite
cookie I have enough I don't need any
more just like you did when you shared
with that man
now I know she got it
this experience still moves me today
because it reminds me that as parents we
are our child's first teachers
as parents and teachers we are used to
research the University of Sussex in the
UK did the largest kindness study of its
time to date sixty thousand participants
were involved and over 140 countries
my biggest takeaway was that
people are unwilling to do kind actions
at times because they are worried about
being misinterpreted in their actions
have you ever had this before I had it
in my story
in fact 70 of respondents felt this way
they felt that they were overthinking it
and felt they didn't want to do it at
that time
so I had thought well is there a way to
remove this kindness barrier
I'm a game changer and I actually
started my lead Journey a couple years
ago I finished in September and like
many of you I have loved this lead
Journey the class that did it for me was
design thinking I took that last March
and in it I asked the question how might
we shape kindness in children
that first how my wheat statement
inspired Pogo a public benefit
Corporation
it was even at last me to read that I
met my co-founder Alana Greene
we are so grateful to share with you
this journey of pogo
Pogo is a digital Marketplace for
kindness what does that even mean
what I attempted to do is put kindness
in an online platform so you can go
there to put kindness that you'd like to
request and actually fulfill kindnesses
of your own that you can find
this is an attempt to remove what we
call the kindness barrier
now what's my call to action as we think
about the community and think about
building our platform
first if you run into this situation
where you can do a kindness embrace it
take that opportunity and do that
kindness for others
second if someone does give you a
kindness thank them for it acknowledge
it it will go a long way simple actions
mean so much to other people
you know the other day I was actually
making baba ganoush as a side for dinner
and I forgot pita bread funny enough so
I decided I would go to Trader Joe's a
local grocery store at 4 pm on a Sunday
it was packed people were everywhere and
some of you might say that was not a
good decision but I did it anyway and I
happened to land the second person in
line the first person in front of me had
a full full cart and I had to make it
home for dinner that person actually
turned to me and said you know what go
ahead
that was such a simple action that made
my day when I left I went out and I
donated to the Girl Scout cookies right
there because these simple actions
really really make a difference
well
what Pago means today I'd love to
explain that to you as well Pogo is
Latin for Village and toupee in Spanish
so paga represents our attempt to create
a village and pay kindness forward in
the world we hope to create a village
where you are sparked by Joy but also
sustains it thank you for listening and
paying it forward with kindness thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]